welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on current
challenges and controversies it is my
pleasure to introduce to you dr. Stephen
Morse dr. Morse is a professor of
Epidemiology at Columbia University
Mailman School of Public Health he also
serves as the director of infectious
disease and as the chair of the Columbia
University institutional biosafety
committee he is an associate editor of
disaster medicine and public health
preparedness previously dr. Moore served
as the program manager for bio defense
at DARPA and he was appointed in 2014 to
the US government's National Science
Advisory Board for biosecurity for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr. Moore's keynote presentation is
titled the next pandemic my name is Judy
O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's laberd's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before begin
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits and now without further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. Stephen
Morse I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you very much I'm glad
to join you today and thank you for the
lovely introduction unfortunately it's a
topic that we all have thought about a
great deal
and still suffer from today so I hope
we'll meet again under happier times
throughout history infectious diseases
have been major causes of disease and
death but also have shaped our history
and our consciousness and so the Black
Death the plague of the 14th century was
a major event that changed the face of
Europe and change European culture
forever afterwards and stave rise to
much literature still very much in our
collective unconsciousness smallpox
which is the only human infectious
disease actually to have been eradicated
is often said to have killed more people
than all of the wars in history combined
and that's probably true of the other
infections cholera and influenza as well
cholera is a great pandemic of the 19th
century but also continues today in many
parts of the world we're seeing a
cholera outbreak right now in Yemen for
example as well as other places like
Bangladesh where it is endemic that is
where it's a regular occurrence but in
the 19th century it became very famous
as it came to Europe via steamships and
caused for example a major outbreak in
Victorian London which Jon Snow very
famously investigated still remembered
today as one of the founders of
Epidemiology using as he put it his five
senses and his notebook to track down
the source of cholera in Victorian
London and he was able to discover
through epidemiology following the cases
and where they were that color was
transmitted by something in the water
supply even though it was not until 25
years later or so that Coke discovered
the organism the bacterium responsible
for
causing cholera and of course the 1918
influenza the great influenza probably
the greatest historical disaster in all
of recorded history killed more people
than any other known single event
overshadowed perhaps by World War one
but actually killed more people than the
war itself we estimate the number of
deaths at about 50 million or more and
of course we just recently observed the
Centennial if you will of the 1918
influenza so these were all events that
changed our consciousness about
infectious diseases and obviously made
us aware of how much infectious diseases
shaped our history and then in the last
hundred years or so we've come to be
take infectious diseases much more for
granted as living conditions improved
and by the middle of the 20th century we
had not only better water and sanitation
and and better nutrition which reduce
the impact impact of many of the
infectious diseases of the past but also
vaccines and antibiotics and we began to
think that infectious diseases could be
relegated to the past unfortunately much
as we might wish that to be so in much
of the world infectious diseases remain
major causes of disease and death even
though in this part of the world in the
industrialized countries we still are
mostly subject to chronic diseases
nevertheless we still have to worry
about infectious diseases for reasons
that all discuss and infections that we
have not previously recognized which I
called emerging infections also appear
I'll discuss why and where they come
from and forgotten infections may also
reappear I called those reemerging
infections and those often include
infections that were once controlled by
public health measures for example
Meisel
which I had in 1957 before there was a
vaccine along with probably a million or
so other children in the United States
with one in probably about one in a
thousand or so fatalities but after the
vaccine became available we no longer
feared measles and we had no reason to
because we had a good vaccine but now of
course we've taken it very much for
granted and we see the reappearance of
measles in certain places where
immunization is not being carried out in
the former Soviet Union and Eastern
Europe during economic crises after the
breakup of the former Soviet Union the
public health measures immunization were
no longer really able to be applied as
readily as they had been in the past
because of economic difficulties and we
saw the reappearance of of such old
fashioned diseases all vaccine
preventable as whooping cough and and
not only measles but also diphtheria
things my mother remembered but that I
had never experienced because of
immunization and then of course all of a
sudden in the 1980s we saw something
that really disturbed our complacency
very much that came as a total surprise
to us and of course that was what we now
call hiv/aids it rose from the early 80s
where it was hardly noticed as an
infection and had probably been going
through Africa for some while before
that we're still debating how long but
when it came into the United States
there were a few cases and then suddenly
its skyrocketed to become the major and
in fact leading cause of death in young
adults healthy young adults aged 25 to
44 as you can see from this slide it
really took off so quickly that it
overtook all the others in a matter of
10 years and this is something that we
never expect to see because we expect
that
healthy young adults will remain healthy
for quite a while there are certain
well-established and and generally
fairly stable causes of death sadly
cancer heart disease and of course
suicide and homicide particularly in
inner-city areas unintentional injuries
like automobile accidents but to see an
infectious disease overtake all of those
was a tremendous surprise it's often
said that American life does not have a
second chapter with HIV we were very
lucky to have a second chapter in the
sense that drugs effective therapies
were developed we now call that we
called it at the time highly effective
antiretroviral therapy you've got to
have heart as some people said at the
time we now call that just
antiretroviral therapy and that's made
it possible to control HIV we talked
about the possibility that if we can
continue this long enough throughout the
world we may actually be able to have
the next generation free of HIV but that
will require sustained effort and to be
able to get to people and treat them for
the next 20 years or so and it's
expensive to do this although there are
a number of efforts to do this
throughout the world and we're hopeful
but of course we need to do this before
the virus itself begins to develop
serious resistance so there are a number
of challenges we will see these same
challenges and opportunities come up
over and over again so as in the case of
HIV it's also fair to say that no
pandemic or emerging infection has ever
been predicted despite all our
possibilities for modeling prediction
and early warning I'll be talking about
that and those are obviously major tools
in our armamentarium nevertheless we've
still never been able to predict
anything and even when we have seen it
coming is in the case of HIV
often we've been too late in taking
appropriate action so it's important to
remember that because those are really
the key take-home messages so more
formally what I called emerging
infections back in the late 1980s HIV
being the one that really gained our
attention most rapidly are those that
rapidly increase an incidence number of
new cases or geographic range often
these are novel previously unrecognized
such as HIV or a new influenza
introduced from from somewhere else in
the world and I'll have a number of
examples to show you the surprising
thing is we often thought that these
might be the Andromeda Strain that was a
book written years ago about some virus
like infection that falls from outer
space but in fact all of these and that
was of course my original interest where
are these coming from and I'll tell you
because the answer unfortunately or
perhaps fortunately is is not
extraterrestrial it's much more mundane
they come from other species in most
cases from inner space from our own
planet and they have a chance to get to
human beings and in some cases to
establish themselves and spread and
those emerging infections that succeed
obviously the ones we we talk about the
most but in many cases anthropogenic
causes things we do are often important
in precipitating and allowing the
emergence and spread of these infections
and that's really the other major
take-home message so as a cartoon
character Pogo said one popular my
childhood we have met the enemy and it
is us but we're not an enemy we're just
really doing things and these are the
unintended consequences so here's a list
of a number of the emerging infections
and there are quite a few but these are
some that have been tabulated in recent
years
going from Ebola all the way of course
to Zika and a number of others in
between a more graphic way to put that
might very well be in the next slide
where you can see this shown in a map
format from my colleagues Tony fowey and
david morons at the National Institutes
of Allergy and Infectious Diseases at
NIH and it's a very dynamic map indeed
we have to change it as new infections
appear occasionally an old one will
disappear but smallpox is the only one
that we think is gone for good and then
we worry about it as a potential
bioterrorism threat or a laboratory
accident so that's left a whole new set
of possibilities but at least it's gone
from nature but you can see that there
are many emerging and re-emerging
infectious diseases all over the world
this slide shows a few of the outbreaks
of concern ebola of course which is
going to be covered in a keynote by
another speaker so i won't say much
about that except that of course as
you'll see we've known about Ebola when
it was a great surprise to all of us in
1976 and that's when we first discovered
if if you will although local people
probably knew about it in its native
Africa for much longer that was the
first time that Western medicine and and
the rest of the world became aware of it
since then there have been about two
dozen outbreaks but the biggest surprise
of course was in 2014 through 2016 in
West Africa where nobody expected ever
to see 20 over 28,000 cases with over
11,000 deaths caused by Ebola we know
Ebola is highly lethal but it had never
caused that many cases I'll show you
more details in a moment the Democratic
Republic of the Congo where one of the
first two Ebola outbreaks was found
simultaneously in 1976 is right now
suffering through one in the eastern
Congo the numbers continue to mount
there are now over 1200 cases these are
lab confirms so you'll see different
numbers but it's a continuing epidemic
so obviously you know it's continuing to
accumulate cases with almost 800 deaths
in North kevo and other areas of the
eastern Congo which also happens to be
one of the worst conflict zones in the
world so one of the things we'll have to
get used to is the relationship between
political conflict and other difficult
situations and outbreaks too often are
closely tied and obviously as I'll show
you in a moment it's very difficult to
work in these areas even if one has
vaccines Zika was very much in the news
a few years ago because it was first
discovered in Africa
in 1947 where it was thought to be a
mild disease when it was first seen in
human beings some years later but since
then it circulated around Africa South
Asia Indonesia for example the Pacific
in Indian Ocean and then made its way to
South America
lirik was responsible for a number of
cases of microcephaly
that is to say abnormalities in brain
and skull development in the developing
fetus if pregnant women happen to catch
it at the wrong time during pregnancy
and became an object of great concern we
still have no vaccine but obviously are
recommending many precautions against
mosquitoes and to prevent contact with
mosquitoes difficult for the people who
live there perhaps easier for those of
us who are traveling but microcephaly
had not been noticed before some of
these other effects in the newborn had
not were in developing fetuses had not
been noticed before
as well as sexual transmission also seen
in Ebola survivors but this was an
enormous outbreak with over 1500
reported cases and probably many more
covering the entire South American much
of Central America and Caribbean region
and a few spots in the southern US so it
really had claimed many more cases than
we had ever seen before falling if you
will on fertile ground I'm personally
interested in something called Middle
East respiratory syndrome caused by a
corona virus this is a the family of
viruses MERS as we call it belongs to
but a distant relative is also the one
that caused SARS very famous starting in
Asia and going round the world in 2003
and of course causing great concern even
then so I think we haven't heard the
last of this family of viruses but I
think there are many others also in
waiting this mirrors was first noticed
in 2012 in Saudi Arabia but actually
there had been some earlier cases
diagnosed retrospectively that is after
the fact and and picked up in Jordan and
noticed in Jordan but there were no
diagnostic tests available than in April
of 2012 and it's since spread it since
can be found throughout the Gulf area
but to give you some idea of the
potential for importation one person in
South Korea who became infected in the
Gulf region and in that part of the
Middle East returned he a business
person returned to South Korea in the
late spring of 2015 and gave rise to at
least a hundred and eighty-five known
cases with 36 deaths all occurring
within the healthcare environment
essentially nosocomial
or Hospital transmitted so this is
something that really makes a strong
case I think for the importance of
hospital infection control because many
of these infections spread very widely
in hospital settings avian influenza
we've worried about of course all of the
avian influenzas and I'll have more to
say about that in a moment and all of
the influenza have provided a number of
surprises I'll mention Ebola very
briefly because much has been said about
that this is how the world first became
aware of the 2014 Ebola outbreak
notice the World Health Organization and
a number of red flags really I hate to
use that cliche but it's really quite
quite immediate
that you can see very quickly when they
talk about a rapidly evolving outbreak
in Africa yes normally these outbreaks
occur in forested areas but rapidly
evolving should really be a warning sign
and when they talk about 49 cases you
know that that's already a fairly large
number that means this has been in
progress for a while so it really should
have gotten our immediate attention
unfortunately as as general as generally
has happened with Ebola we almost always
respond but usually after delay of
several months in this case that delay
was very unfortunate because although
for the first few months the Ebola
outbreak might have been containable it
rapidly took off in those three West
African countries Guinea were originated
in a forested area as Ebola outbreaks
always do but of course these are
contiguous this area is contiguous with
parts of Liberia and Sierra Leone where
people move very quickly and then move
to the capital cities and to other large
cities in order to get help and they're
in the cities with the dense population
we think that the Ebola outbreak was
able to take off very rapidly there was
no change in Ebola no
changing the transmissibility the bola
which is not really enormous
it's about as transmissible as the flu
but is not transmissible by the
respiratory route only essentially by
touch by contact with infected
secretions or corpses and so during
burial ceremonies preparing bodies for
burial very sadly or contact with
infected secretions do people become
infected but in an urban environment
obviously when people are living close
together there are many such
opportunities and that's what we saw
happening added to that was the local
suspicion of the government which had
had civil wars in all of these countries
and in which in all of these countries
the governments were not trusted and
therefore the governments really could
not get to the places where for example
West Point a rather low resource heavily
populated area in Monrovia the capital
of Liberia where there was quite a bit
of spread of Ebola but of course we
became concerned when there was the
possibility that it could come here
actually bola does not have a natural
ecology that would allow it to become
established here I'll come back to that
point but we could see occasional cases
in close contacts of infected people
indeed we saw that or in hospital
settings if people are not properly
prepared the caregivers are not properly
prepared and indeed we saw that in
Dallas when someone came back from
Liberia but in New York we became
concerned about the possibility of Ebola
coming here and then one of my
colleagues Craig Spencer who had been
doing good a good work working on
patients with Ebola helping medicines on
friend Frontier Doctors Without Borders
during the outbreak came back here and
was promptly given the appropriate
treatment and isolation because there
was a great deal of concern here during
this period by
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention CDC and by the local health
department's such as the New York City
Department of Health that we have the
appropriate measures in place in case
people came back so Craig Spencer as
soon as he became sick which is the only
time people can actually transmit Ebola
to others in in the initial phases did
all the right things and was put into
isolation at Bellevue Hospital which had
already been prepared and trained and
had everything in place to take care of
that person or anybody who came back
with Ebola however of course you know
people were roundly vilified that it
that is demonized for for the good work
they had done and I think that's that's
very unfortunate when it's all about us
unfortunately you know sometimes we lose
perspective but the reality is that
Ebola is only likely in this country to
to be a concern to those who are in
close contact with the infected and
again health care workers now we made
these mistakes despite having a history
since 1976 of two dozen outbreaks of
Ebola but most of them had been solved
and within fairly limited remote areas
where they're forested and I'll come
back to why this happens but basically
they come to us from other species that
are what we would call the natural hosts
or reservoirs for Ebola and just
accidentally get into the human
population which is why Ebola is so
trance oh-oh-oh-oh-oooh to person it
really has not had luckily for us much
experience nor does it really depend on
us
for its survival it depends on other
species to maintain this virus in nature
but we haven't learned from all those
earlier experiences and perhaps became a
little complacent unfortunately the
current event with Ebola right now is in
a place where there is tremendous
conflict at least
the 1990s and the genocide nearby and
Rwanda and so there's great concern
about the violence in the eastern Congo
which is also making it very difficult
for people to work there and and to save
lives on top of all of the other things
that need to be done with Ebola there is
a vaccine now for the first time that
became available at the end of the last
2014 outbreak in West Africa and all
people in neighboring areas are becoming
are getting immunized and their attempts
to immunize people in the places where
there is the greatest likelihood of
exposure where their Ebola outbreaks but
this is very difficult because of the
conflict occurring there so we have by
no means solve that problem although we
have better tools than we ever did we at
least hopefully appreciate the
possibilities that Ebola can reach urban
areas and cause more cases than we
imagined even if that might be
geographically limited it can still be a
tragic event another event that is less
pandemic in nature that is less global
in nature but still obviously has caused
a number of cases and concern is as I
mentioned Middle East respiratory
syndrome or MERS and MERS was first
identified in 2012 the first cases were
in Jordan in April of 2012 and then
later in in Saudi Arabia where most of
the cases have appeared but as I
mentioned one accidental introduction
through the healthcare system in South
Korea caused a large outbreak so health
care workers really need to be careful
and many of the cases in the mirror's
outbreaks in the Middle East are also
healthcare associated so far as you can
see there have been a number of big
spikes and a number of cases I showed
number in
earlier slide so it's a cause of great
concern because we obviously you know
don't know if it's going to stop where
it is although it's probably again very
much tied to its natural setting where
do the people originally who come in is
what we call primary or the initial
cases of MERS actually get it a lot of
investigation has suggested that it's
probably dromedary camels and there are
related viruses that can be found in
dromedary camels in much of the Middle
East and North Africa but the ones that
cause human infections seem to be
geographically limited to these new
outbreaks of what we call mirrors and so
very likely dromedary camels are the
source of at least half of the primary
human MERS coronavirus infections
however there are a number they're still
unexplained including those initial
cases in Jordan and of course many that
occur through the health care setting
but the one that really keeps me up at
night of course is influenza
one of my former professors Howard Taman
who won the Nobel Prize for his work on
what is now called reverse transcriptase
everybody now uses it in the lab to
convert RNAs into DNA copies but at the
time he proposed it in the 1960s
everybody thought it was a radical
notion so Howard I give great great
tribute to him was a great pioneer and
something of an iconoclast as well as a
very imaginative thinker but he used to
say that talking about influenza as an
emerging infection perhaps is cheating
but in fact influenza is the only
infection I know of at least among the
viruses that fits all of the
requirements or all of the imagined
criteria we think of with an emerging
infection
most of these are ZOA notic infections
that is infections of other species that
find their way into the human population
with greater or lesser success and
greater or lesser mortality but
influenza continues to evolve as well as
being able to infect human beings in a
number of ways so I think it actually is
fascinating and highly unpredictable so
influenza viruses infect a wide variety
of birds and mammals the natural host it
was discovered in the 1970s are actually
migratory waterfowl that's where you can
find the greatest variety of influenza
viruses and most of the time we're
talking about influenza we're talking
about type-a that's the variety the
major influenza type that causes
pandemics type B can cause disease also
especially in children and can be
responsible for deaths so we do include
that in our vaccine we hardly ever
mention type C because it seems to show
very little variation over time and
that's a very interesting question why
some influenza viruses are highly
variable and others are not but type A
is the one we most worry about and it's
the one I'm going to be talking about
this is in a way something of a tribute
to one of my other mentors who got me
started on the question of emerging in
fact in Joshua Lederberg than the
president of Rockefeller University
where I was working at the time who got
me started thinking about emerging
infectious diseases as a result of some
very well-placed questions but he was
also a very imaginative and
forward-thinking person and an early
adopter of technology so I pay tribute
to Josh Lederberg who's Nobel Prize was
as they put it very simply for
discovering mechanisms of sex in
bacteria
two of the three mechanisms for
bacterial gene transfer including
horizontal gene transfer by conjugation
which is where most of the antibiotic
resistance at least the major antibiotic
resistance genes get transferred and
that we worry about in terms of
antibiotic resistance came from Josh
Lederberg work and his colleagues
but in any case here's a little diagram
of the influenza virus type a you can
see has eight RNA segments so its genome
is RNA as are many other viruses they
all have many different oddities and in
the various genomic experiments they've
done and those eight segments those
think of them as microscopic chromosomes
give the opportunity for what we call
reassortment mixing and matching as well
as for the possibility of mutation in
each of those segments and both of those
things occur the most that's the parts
that are greatest concern to us
generally and that are included in the
vaccines are the hemagglutinin surface
protein this is a surface protein coded
by the H a gene and there are 18 or so
known subtypes and probably more out
there seventeen that are known in other
species and at least a dozen or so that
have been associated with avian or
mammalian infections and that's the one
that we usually make antibodies against
and therefore that's usually in the
vaccine neuraminidase which some people
call molecular scissors the opposite
affect the hemagglutinin is the receptor
that allows the virus to get into the to
attach to the cellular receptor and
allow the virus to get in but it's
neuraminidase that allows progeny virus
the offspring to get it out and not be
stuck to the cellular neuraminidase in
the cell or on the surface of the cell
so many of our current therapeutics are
so called neuraminidase inhibitors they
prevent the virus from getting out of
the salad initially in facts but those
are the two major surface proteins that
have been the target of most of our
vaccine efforts to date now new
influenza strains can arise by one of
two possible mechanisms
antigenic drift so-called is mutation
basically in the hemagglutinin gene
usually or sometimes in one of the other
surface proteins but almost always it's
the mutation it's mutations in the
hemagglutinin gene which is then able to
escape our immune system and reinfect
people if you will old wine in new
bottles until we our immune systems
recognize it and take care of it but
until then it's able to infect and
propagate and this is the mechanism for
the so-called annual periodic or
seasonal influenza by the way every
known human seasonal influenza is
actually the direct progeny of a
pandemic influenza virus this is the
first time in history since the 1970s
that we've seen more than one type or
subtype as we would call it of type A
coexisting which is very end interesting
probably not a peaceful coexistence
they usually trade off but it's been a
very interesting a very frustrating time
until 1977 every single seasonal
influenza was really the result of
mutations in the major pandemic strain
that had take gained a foothold as a
result of pandemic but the pandemic
influenza do not result as a result of
mutations they come about by what we
call antigenic shift in the old days
reassortment of gene segments between
different influenza viruses often with a
novel hemagglutinin gene that makes it
look very different from from what human
being M&M system has been exposed to
before influenza is not a trivial
disease even in terms of the ordinary or
seasonal influenza so called seasonal
periodic influenza as I don't like
unfortunately those terms because there
not strictly seasonal periodic might be
a better term but we don't really have a
good vocabulary it's been estimated that
there at least generally 20,000 deaths
in a an ordinary light influenza year
attributable to influenza in the u.s.
that's an estimate we can't always be
sure and in more recent years 36,000
deaths probably last year it was closer
to 80,000 because it was a very heavy
influence a year not the current season
but the one before and in globally this
probably means something on the
neighborhood of a quarter to a half
million deaths now typically this is an
elderly and the very young very old or
people like myself over 60 and infants
except for a pandemic years when you may
see other effects because so many people
are infected but there are other
underlying medical conditions that could
also or may be reasons that we're not
entirely aware of when people might also
become susceptible and get severely ill
or die we worry about influenza
pandemics technically that's an epidemic
that is so geographically widespread
essentially so large that it involves a
very large area essentially the entire
world for influenza what that requires
is a novel human subtype one that's been
unfamiliar to humans in the past or at
least in living memory so that when h1
reappeared in recent years it was a bit
of a surprise 1918 was an h1 but all of
these others as as new hemagglutinin
types get into the population they have
pandemic potential because they have
been they're unfamiliar at least to
living humans and they also need to be
able to spread sufficiently from person
to person then what I mean by that is
essentially about as well
as ordinary or garden-variety influenza
sometimes not even as well because most
of the pandemics have not spread awfully
well but they spread about as well not
quite as well as your ordinary seasonal
influenza so here are a few examples of
some of the things we've worked in the
past the greatest pandemic of all and
the greatest natural disaster probably
in all of the recorded history the 1918
pandemic which is the h1n1 subtype so
every time something like h1 and one
comes back we worry that we may be
seeing the reappearance of something
like the Spanish influenza the 1918
influenza nothing to do with Spanish
origin they just happened to be the
first country to report it because they
weren't in the World War one at the time
but in 1976 we mistakenly thought that
it might be reappearing and of course
perhaps acted too swiftly but on the
other hand better perhaps to be too fast
than not not to be fast enough because
we saw 50 million deaths or possibly
more due to that great influence of 1918
that's been a unique event in history
and hopefully will remain a unique event
for as long as we're all alive but we
never know when or if it could happen
again in 1957 I had it myself
there was the milder but still serious
so-called Asian flu which is designated
h2n2 and had the pattern in most cases
of being most severe in in the old and
the young and the same was true in 1968
the Hong Kong flu so called h3n2 between
them they probably caused about four and
a half million deaths but in 1918 this
was a major event you can see here how
people worried about it in each city and
how young healthy people being mobilized
world war one here's a military camp in
in Kansas were rapidly
tricking down and many of them died and
in fact you see an uncharacteristic
mortality curve here you see in the
dotted lines the characteristic
mortality of 1918 of normal influenza
that so called u-shaped or bathtub curve
the mostly the young mostly the elderly
with a few in between of some other
medical condition and probably pregnant
women as well to some degree in 1918
suddenly there's a big peak in young
healthy adults and that as I mentioned
earlier should always really raise
concerns we saw that with with hiv/aids
we certainly should have immediately
done something and been concerned about
that we saw that with 1918 influenza and
some of the Ebola cases as well so this
really should be something that that
warns you that something unusual is
going on there's been a lot of debate
about why that particular age group and
they're interesting questions there
which I won't get into but the mortality
was high enough in that group to
actually cause a temporary spike in u.s.
mortality rates due to infectious
disease which was falling at that time
and how do these how do these pandemic
influenza Sakr we've never been entirely
certain and we're still not entirely
sure but the best hypothesis is that or
the best working idea right now and
there's quite a bit of evidence for it
to support it is that the reservoir
house as I mentioned all the influenza
viruses in their great variety can be
found in various migratory waterfowl of
the world and so ducks and other
livestock that are similar to that are
also able to catch or harbour many of
these influenza viruses and in many
parts of the world including China where
many of the past pandemics have
originated for reason as we
our beginning only now to understand and
still don't really understand fully
there is a very efficient agricultural
system that puts the ducks and the pigs
arms neck to the next to the duck ponds
very efficient integrated agriculture
but also pigs seem to be mixing vessels
that are capable of getting a number of
different kinds of influenza that humans
are resistant to but that might well
make various combinations in new
reassortant in the pig and be able to
more readily infect humans when when the
pig farmer comes and and comes in
contact with me infected pigs who may
very off sometimes have disease or may
very often have no obvious disease well
we thought we knew the rules for
influenza pandemics and even seasonal
influenza in the past all the human
infections had been with subtypes
hemagglutinin types one two or three
weed seed some mild human infections
with the avian influenza known as h7 but
never really serious disease in humans
only poultry that changed considerably
in 1997 when suddenly saw an outbreak
they tried n one not very famous and
avian influenza in poultry in Hong Kong
there are actually a couple of different
similar but different h5n1 influenza
viruses because they they do have
different mutations as well as as these
very four big classifications categories
and we found some union deaths they were
in confirmed cases in Hong Kong with six
deaths at all ages interestingly enough
as some young some sort of distribution
that mean age was 17 so he had a
distribution of Ages and that should
warned us about something as well as
people working in in the hospital where
these cases occurred so they picked it
up in their natural living environments
but then came to the ha
but where others could become infected
although all of these initially got
infected in the hospital Hong Kong
closed down the poultry markets and so
as a result h5 went underground for a
while
continued to evolve in its natural
sources and suddenly reappeared with the
great vengeance later in 2003 first in
poultry and then obviously we worried a
lot about these avian influenzas because
we started seeing cases and human beings
and I showed you in an earlier slide the
counts with h5 and one in a number of
places in Asia and also many cases in
Egypt in in poultry that's been largely
controlled through a lot of assiduous
efforts or maybe it's it's died out for
other reasons as well but then we've
seen a number of other avian influenzas
suddenly get our attention
so there's a real question question
about not just when the chicken will
cross the road but when will it's
viruses cross the road to human beings
as shown in that that New Yorker cover
some years ago hopefully that's a rare
event but one we have to be prepared for
so far the next major pandemic in 2009
was more conventional in nature although
it was not an avian influenza luckily
for us and we don't think that's likely
to be the next pandemic but I wouldn't
put any bets on that we've been wrong
every time we've tried to predict it so
I've given up trying to predict until we
have a better way for doing it so how do
these infections actually emerge III
thought of this initially as kind of a
mysterious thing the Andromeda Strain
something like that and I thought most
of the mystery was in that introduction
step that first step where something
could occur that introduced a new
infection into the human population from
somewhere or that somehow maybe
something evolved to become the new
Andromeda Strain and it turned out to be
something more mundane in many cases but
I'll talk about what
I called the introduction staff and then
establishment or dissemination some
people would break that into three steps
now so it would be a three rather than
two step process you can conceptualize
any this anyway is easiest for you but I
was most interested in where do these
come from and the reality is the
opportunities of environmental change
and human changes changes in human
habitats actually provide many
opportunities to increase both of these
steps so the first step in the
introduction to actually my great
surprise as a microbiologist when you
look at all of these causes many of
these are so a notic and so the
evolutionary events have occurred before
with the great diversity of of these
microbes or afterwards with adaptation
to the human host which often as in the
case of ebola has not yet occurred
occurred and they never occur but HIV
should be a cautionary tale and so many
of these are so anodic and what i call
the zone otic pool the infections out
there in other species mostly other
vertebrate species especially mammals
but also some avian species is a rich
source of potential emerging pathogens
and changes in the environment they
simply put humans in contact with the
natural hosts of these of these
different infections and allow them to
become infected in most cases we
probably never notice anything but every
so often one of them hits the jackpot
just like a new pandemic influenza and
suddenly it's off and running and we
have something new to worry out or
respond to food animals as well as
wildlife are a concern as possibilities
for human infection so one of my
colleagues actually tried to catalog
this a few years ago and came to the
conclusion that about half of those and
the majority of those that have recently
merged that has been noticed since World
War two when perhaps we've had greater
capabilities to notice them are zoonotic
mean to us from other species rather
than the the Andromeda Strain were
coming from suddenly evolutionary new
evolutionary events and these are a few
examples HIV although it's hard to find
a smoking gun from chimpanzees and other
non-human primates in the case of HIV -
I'll show you in a moment
Ebola probably from bats although there
may be other hosts that are linked to us
such as some non-human primates and some
other animals as well
smallpox and monkey pox now very much in
the news in Africa has a similar natural
ecology in forested areas but probably
its natural host as an Ebola but its
natural host is probably rodents and
most of the parks viruses and despite
their name cowpox monkey pox smallpox
smallpox adapted eventually becoming
human disease which is why we can
eradicate it but almost all of these
seem to originate in rodents and they
have the greatest variety of these parks
viruses including the Miss nay the Miss
nomer monkey pox the original Andromeda
Strain
came in the 60s and and killed very
rapidly in parts of Nigeria where a
number of medical missionary
establishments were wiped out very
quickly it's the disease we now call
Lassa fever and also carried as a
natural infection by certain other
rodents we all know about rodents and
the plague especially rats the subject
of much science as well as much
literature even today Khem news the the
plague la peste written in the 20th
century about an event that actually
occurred in his native Iran in Algeria
in 1947 and although it's really about
the Nazi occupation of of that area of
France it's also scientifically pretty
accurate SAR as we think came from in
fact we have pretty good evidence came
from it
probably a small bath through the live
animal food trade and MERS very likely
through from a camel but may have had a
bad origin and I've also talked about
influenza and there are places of
greater biodiversity where there are
also more human beings who may be
becoming in with it more and more we
might call those as some of my
colleagues have hot sauce for emerging
infections and of course many changes in
the environment provide opportunities
for pathogens to get to the human
population especially agriculture and
various kinds of land-use changes simply
because those are the ways in which we
most often radically change the
environment and then are in contact our
selves with it and that's why what we
call one health is important
these are infections that are often
crossing species from the environment so
we need to think about the infections of
other species and there have been
efforts such as the US Agency for
International Development emerging
pandemic threats predict project which I
led for the first five years now
entering and ending its second five-year
cycle but there may be some some other
future efforts under different names to
try to find out what's out there even if
we can't quite gay which of them are the
ones we might most worried about we're
learning at least to get somewhat better
at predicting them at least cataloging
what might be waiting in the wings
potentially but many of these are
infections of other species so we need
to know about that we need to know
obviously about human behavioural
conditions and environmental conditions
and environmental change so a hotel I
stayed at for a meeting a few years ago
this just coincidentally happened to be
there I don't think they knew we were
coming for an emerging infections
meeting wildlife should be respected but
there are many infections since they're
the obviously numerous and
have the greatest number of species in
in nature wildlife have been pointed out
you know as one of the initial sources
for future emerging infections how do
they get to us wildlife contact is one
live animal markets food handling and of
course hunting all of which are attempts
our food essentially gathering efforts
and modern agriculture and infection
control health care settings my
colleague Laurie Garrett referred to
hospitals in the health care setting as
amplifiers for merging infections and
many infections that may have started
out with very limited possibilities have
unfortunately spread through healthcare
settings it's really hard to do rigorous
infection control as we saw with those
with that initial Ebola introduction in
the Dallas hospital were two nurses who
survived became infected because they
were not appropriately trained or
equipped by their system so there are
many examples of wildlife livestock
contact this is a picture I took in when
I was in Cambodia those are water
buffalo roaming loose but they're also
livestock which will come back across
the river to be tended by by their human
farmer living across the river and
there's also there are also other
opportunities for wildlife human contact
even bats in Africa here's a young man
showing off his his back collection if
you will by a photo taken in the photo
taken by the collar by a colleague and
then of course there are many
opportunities through the live animal
market and and food trade as we believe
happened with avian influenza in live
animal markets and of course I won't
show any videos here I'll spare you that
I friends who who have them but that's
believe it or not being sold in live
animal markets which could which were
the natural hosts the reservoirs for
SARS coronavirus and could spread SARS
to other food species and also team and
beings who handled either of those
luckily for us there are a lot of
candidates but few of them are
successful however human activities may
disseminate a localized infection or
create hot air ways for microbe traffic
to get to new areas also environmental
changes as I mentioned and this is a
process that's accelerating we have a
very widespread global aviation network
that makes globalisation a good thing in
many ways but also has unintended
consequences and that's also true of
international tourism so there are
possibilities for once limited
infectious infections to get into the
human population whereas they may once
have been hard to get to luckily for us
this is not easier to do
transmissibility is a requirement it's
not enough just to be a pin fact
somebody it has to have some natural
environment that it can settle down in
which is why Ebola is not likely to
establish itself in the US or probably
Western Europe and to be transmissible
in some way flu has been a great success
so has HIV this is a picture of HIV
infecting a cell and we're less certain
although we have very good evidence
about HIV one with HIV 2 the geographic
spread has been much more limited and so
we can trace it to a few specific places
in West Africa and to the range of a
monkey we call the city mangabey that
has close contact with humans and like
all other animals is also hunted food so
this is probably how HIV 1 2 and a
number of others originally got into the
human population and there are many
other possibilities existing today in a
protein deprived world there are many
factors I've characterized about a half
dozen or so factors or some people
prefer to call them drivers in emergence
of infectious diseases
I mentioned ecological change but of
course there are a number of
that I've already touched on including
thought the food contact food processing
and the food industry and healthcare as
I mentioned through blood products
tissue products or infection control
measures not being rigorously followed
so that's important I've talked about
microbial adaptation and change and of
course that's very much in evidence with
antimicrobial resistance and breakdown
public health measures we see that with
the so called vaccine preventable
diseases even measles in the developed
wealthy countries which I called
reemerging infections so where do these
first warnings first come from almost
all of them depend on somebody noticing
and telling people and traditionally
this is a hierarchical system in recent
years let me go back to that slide just
to show you that it comes from labs and
practitioners that is clinicians who are
astute enough to tell local officials of
governments and and then it works its
way up the chain of many a slip twixt
cup and lip in that many broken links in
that chain and so there's been a lot of
interest in making more distributed more
Bottoms Up grassroots system to be able
to get more inputs one example of this
was something we called Pro med mill the
program for monitoring emerging diseases
which we started in the 1990s so I'll
just give a a small plug if I may for
pro med male promed started to improve
the global surveillance infectious
disease and was called the program for
monitoring infectious monitoring
emerging diseases in the late actually
early 1990s late 1980s and eventually
thanks to Josh Lederberg since nobody
had some easy way to communicate
suggested getting everyone all over the
world we had 60 original laboratories
and scientists throughout the world
including an afro
Asia and the former Soviet Union and
Russia then the Soviet Union and decided
and and Kurtis appalled Josh Burgess all
to get onto email which then was I will
add a very painful experience very diff
from today's web which did not exist
when we started promed bill in the 1990s
we've got everyone on to email as a
method for communication and then found
that this was really the fundamentals
for an outbreak reporting system that we
could make available to everybody it's
now available free to all anyone who
gets email or the web now can get access
to it and even contribute to the
conversation there are about seventy
thousand subscribers in 185 countries
and you can get it on the web or you can
get emails I recommend promed EDR it is
what we call moderated which is to say
there are subject matter experts who
look at it and try to get verification
there's now a formal system within the
pronet organization to do that it was a
simple query from one of our colleagues
on promed who is well qualified as you
can see that asked about a respiratory
disease in south china and led china to
admit that it had 305 cases of what we
now call SARS which then made its way by
time it made its way to hong kong
managed to spread around the world
including toronto unfortunately it was
only noticed when it and china only
admitted to those earlier cases when
when word came through promed mail and
and sort of the cat got out of the bag
in this case the bat got out of the bag
but also obviously became a worldwide
event we sort of got a backhanded
compliment from this is a book i
recommend if you're interested in john
snow and cholera and the work done on by
john snow and his colleagues but
it's calls promed mail the most
terrifying news source known to mankind
and that it's kind of a backhanded
compliment I think there's even more to
be afraid of these days but now there
are more capabilities for being able to
report you know even at the grassroots
if you will that in this case almost
literally level and so we have a lot of
possibilities for being able to do
better we do know interspecies transfer
is an important source of of infection
I'm sorry is an important source of
potential infection which really
underscores the value of the one health
approach and that we human beings often
are inadvertently responsible and have
to really be aware of these of these
unintended consequences and try to guard
against them and prevent them so
surveillance global surveillance and
early warning which is still evolving we
do have better tools for that and that
is the first and necessary step
however forewarned is not necessarily
forearmed we saw that with the Ebola
outbreaks especially in 2014 so it's not
enough simply to be warned we also need
to act and we are still working on
appropriate response capabilities how
really to respond appropriately and in a
timely fashion and calibrate that so
that it's appropriate to the actual need
and is done early so that's still a
challenge and the other major challenge
is sustainability as I mentioned with
HIV so that we can keep up those
successes in the case of Zika this is a
mosquito-borne infection that mosquito
was introduced with the slave trade into
the new world in the 17th century but
that mosquito has survived all these
years and has transmitted a number of
infections introduced later into the new
world there was an attempt to control it
which has in recent years gone by the
wayside
unfortunately allowing the mosquito also
to come back in force and allowing new
infections as well as more familiar ones
carried by that miss
Kito yellow-fever originally but now
dengue and in more recent years Zika to
gain a real foothold and spread very
rapidly
wherever that mosquito is found so it
was a failure of sustainability of those
mosquito control programs that made us
susceptible to Zika again here are some
other sources one can go to for outbreak
and up-to-date information and thank you
very much for your time and attention
and stay healthy
thank you dr. Morse for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions submitted via email that's all
for now thank you for joining us and
we'll see you next time goodbye